[Music]
started siren what a show thank you have
ever wanted to trap 12 women on an
island what okay for a competition game
show for a competition game it's a great
TV show you so you trap 12 women on an
island
that's more than that it's this insane
so there's physical 100
which was like awesome Korean athletic
uh you know whatever competitive media
so there's siren survive the island and
what they do is they take six groups of
women from different professions so
there's firefighters military uh
athletes
yep yep police bodyguards and then yeah
stunt yeah women okay the way the show
starts is they all compete uh for a grid
order with this really difficult
challenge they have to like march across
like a mud flat get a flag and then
March it back as a team and put it in a
flagpole okay and so depending on the
the results It lines the teams one
through six and then from there they
pick
their location on the island so they
have different cabins
uh there's like you know there's one
location that's basically a shitty tent
but it's the most difficult place to get
to oh I see there's a cabin that's in a
very Central area but there's different
ways to get inside it so
oh what like it's there's like they beat
each other up yes yeah
it's capture the flag in the most
extreme way so your base has a flag and
then you each individually have a flag
so when they ring the siren which can
happen at any point in the day yeah
every 24 hours they can ring the siren
okay your team has to get up and decide
are you gonna stay in defend are you
going to go try to capture okay and so
there's just all this crazy strategy of
you know okay let's send two of us out
let's send one of us out whatever and
you can fight they get there's I'm only
on episode I'm halfway through the
second episode but you can tell
they've gotten physical but they've
learned it seems like the cast members
have learned there's really no rules so
I think the next capture is probably
gonna be murder yeah well bro
on the first capture
they like [__] yeah it feels crazy
it's violent it's like zombies really oh
yeah dude it's like a full team on like
one person on the ground just trying to
like a flag but it's like the [__] out
of it it looks crazy yeah it's like five
people oh yeah and if they get the flag
then they're out yeah they're out for
that
um battle is what they would call it the
team flag gets out then you're off the
you're done on the show oh I see so
there's always people defending the flag
you would think okay but so yeah wow
that sounds awesome yeah and the sound
of the siren itself is
[__] intense oh yeah boy the show is
called siren no um the host his name is
siren he's actually a K-pop Star siren
yeah
and then what do they get if they win
the whole thing nothing
it's just like just an honor it's just
one yeah yeah they just won and what's
crazy they don't even get like a siren
no like a novelty little no they don't
even win like a lunch or dinner with Bob
siren no afterwards oh also what's
really cool is they have a store
and this the mechanic of the store is
the currency is calories burned
so
uh the the people who like Were Far Away
went to the store and they realized that
they had a [__] ton of currency because
they're so far away so to get back and
forth from everything they were burning
tons of calories just they have like
watches on yeah everything yeah and
there's a gym so like if they want to
get like food they're like running the
treadmill for a while yeah why do they
do that though to exhaust them or to
like make them more tired well and to
give different teams different
advantages because you can buy [__] like
food and you can also buy like smoke
bombs and stuff yeah and like nails and
axes to like fortify your base it should
be a video game it's pretty much like
Counter-Strike without guns yeah
oh I've been heavy on that too I'm back
the [__] on really the Cs is it's not
good man how much are you playing today
uh
uh I'm logging some hours that's the
gross feeling I get when I play
Counter-Strike I'm like this is not
useful yeah for anything yeah but I am
getting really good at picking mid on um
[__] I'm so old like on Mirage what's
picking mid what is that
um so if you're the Opera for the team
that's the sniper rifle
um usually maps are kind of broken into
Lanes essentially so there's usually
middle there's B there's a and then the
two bomb sites have their own like
characteristics but middle of the map is
just referred to as mid
picking mid
kind of like how you kind of like kind
of like how like when you shop and when
you look at shoes [__] you you're
picking me
I knew that was gone I'm sorry that was
stupid and cheap
um kind of like your shoes but yeah
these are not myths
these are sick yeah no for sure yeah
brain dead exactly brain dead Converse
Club yeah dude counter-strike's really
cool it's really attractive you got to
hit that ten thousand hours yeah every
time I play Elena's like [__] this is
why I married you yeah it's so hot
you're so hot I love when you talk in
that verbiage yeah I love when you use
utility utility yeah
up on Main yeah up going main yeah yeah
she hears that from the next room oh my
God yeah she's like oh
she calls it and she calls her boyfriend
yeah yeah he's my husband's actually
being hot right now I think I'm gonna
pass tonight yeah he's playing
Counter-Strike I know he's just so
irresistible
[Laughter]
the best is when you get owned in CS2
and it's never your fault what why was
he looking there hey yeah that's the
go-to what the [__] why would you look
there yeah he's hacking yeah he's for
sure hacking now what everyone does now
is they go
yeah I don't know about that
like they don't want to they don't I'm
not gonna say it but it's like I don't
know about that was just kind of suss to
me why do you peek around the corner
like I don't know he knew I was there
you know I had this like uh I wanted to
put up a bounty I want to do a
Counter-Strike reality show oh I wanted
to do the same thing that the UFC does
with
um
uh
what the how do I forget the name of
this series
it's like their most popular it's like
the reality show Ultimate Fighter yes
yeah God uh oh my God I watched the
scariest clip from that [__] show but
sorry keep going yeah I just want to do
the same thing where I wanted to get a
bunch of guys that are just just not
good enough to play for the big teams I
want to get 30 of them in a house and
just do physical challenges to weed them
out and then the remaining
uh
uh two team leaders get nominated and
then they get they pick from the
remaining guys in the house that's good
and then just put up a cash prize like a
crazy Bounty like
um
yeah you guys are going to I don't know
maybe build some structure where it's
like a four week thing and by the end
they're gonna play for like [__] 500
000 no put a bunch put a bunch of like
treadmills or something in there and
then make uh yeah they have to buy food
with calories yeah yeah just steal from
siren yeah which actually would work
yeah definitely you make the game of
Counter-Strike painful yeah
I mean it's is it is it harder to play
like after a workout it probably is
right yeah yeah you kind of those are
like reflexes or worse like you're uh
fine-tuned muscles or whatever although
I will say what's the word I'm looking
for motor skills motor skills uh no the
uh switch muscles yeah tired yeah I'll
say this
after a little after a little workout
and a little Shake
a little cool down CS feels good does it
yeah you're like I'm not I was in the I
was in the lazy piece of [__] today so
yeah yeah I earned this and he played
for eight hours yeah and you don't eat
you don't hit any of your [__] yeah
dietary goals none of that yeah man